talked about generally about training
tomorrow and I will try to pick it up
what do you do when you have basically
change model a little bit about me I
need section recommendations we had an
e-commerce company and for my family I
mean the work on visual search
recommendations and accreditation
I used to the recommender systems Hinch
which was a social dating app and in
fact that I worked a number of startups
it didn't quite make it for the certain
material I have a number of notebooks
you can either click on this URL and or
this Europe and through did through the
tutorial you can kind of look at the
notebooks but also if you have these
three steps Python 3 talker tip 3 and
this would be also useful because we are
going to be using talkers quite a bit to
be able to stand up various transfer
flow model serving pass-through ETF
serving we yes
I'm sure you mean here or maybe make it
bigger
yeah sure
you can't click on this link this is
like a [ __ ] drilling which is exactly
same if you don't want to type it it is
they slash my name and - TF I can make
it bigger if it is not
[Music]
and so the idea is you click on this
link and then it will go back to the
original thing if you don't want to you
can teach me either transmitters or
email for any questions that you may
have either during the tutorial or after
the tutorial well people are sitting up
can I see some hands how many people are
students how many people know how to do
get or post request
okay how many people have used talker
how many people have used peep perfect
and how many people have used as the
flow in some capacity so the general
setup I'll give a couple of minutes for
setting this up if you don't have
already stock talker you will still be
able to follow a certain mode books but
it will be it will be necessary to be
able to run them for certain and
notebooks and then on the main DirecTV
has requires a txt file which has all of
our and a third party dependencies there
and for the environment you can just
easily clone these people and then the
dependencies installation in this step
for docker setup you can just run docker
do that so let's say we get out people
you can do cloak will be out top and
then we should basically give the
meaning which docker file to be able to
just see if the doctor set up the
actually is working on your on your
local machine
we are going to run this a docker file
for the personal hook in the background
I already built the image so I'm just
gonna run this so that when dr. Fields
it produces a shot that you can kind of
plant that image and then we can just
run this by exposing a port which is
going to be again important we want to
expose an HTTP endpoint court I'm going
to explain this kind of later this is
just that you can you have your talker
set up correctly everything is working
fine and so forth
otherwise in the personal book we are
not going to use this in a second we are
going here this
yes
in them basically when you kolandra pop
in the main directory you can do darker
built dot and then that will basically
start building your main image what is
an image I will come I will come later
it is basically running a transfer full
of image I will explain this yeah you
know in detail maybe make it this large
much larger this is basically dockerfile
content and it is a piece moment image
it does installed tensor preserving for
you transsexual model service we will
copy of a number of paths in having the
people kind of like models that we want
we are going to use the transsexual
serving secret and then exposes it 500gr
pca part it's 501 HTTP REST API part and
then it will run a best script under the
hood but I will come this later
yeah this is just to make sure that you
have doctor environment setup
and I'm pointers kind of explains the
directories that are in the telling the
notebooks and in the again report you
can just do Jupiter notebook let me do
it in here and then stepping up the
notebooks in the directory so a little
bit background until today most people
talk about training modeling kind of the
learner portion of the mission learning
pipeline today I'm going to focus on
when you're headed model how actually
you would deploy that model into
production especially in the systems
that the latency is really important it
needs to be dynamic so you cannot really
produce the predictions of line
generally data science workflow or what
most people do it is my experiences you
train the model you have put that model
and then on the prediction side you
produce the predictions on a test set or
a said that you don't know and then you
start the predictions in database and
then you start the predictions there but
the main motivation of this talk is not
every single problem is can be solved
through offline prediction computation
for example search most of the data
queries are very dynamic and we want to
customize the results so we actually
need to do a prediction on run time
based on the customer data as well as
based on the query that we may not have
seen before
this is kind of the main idea why kind
of discharging players or the prediction
there is important and why we want this
layer to be online and serving kind of
real-time to class
the first notebook I am going to explain
tensorflow serving this is you you don't
have to run this it is a number of
images and a number of Martin I kind of
like opening the images even become
pythons I did add it this way the this
is a pool of liability if we are going
to use for other images to be loaded and
today I was a surprise I guess
throughout this conference I would also
be surprised that I didn't hear as much
chance to show up because tensorflow is
one of the first deep learning libraries
that have an open source which is really
mature library it is like really good
community support has ton of models by
open source by Google and at this point
it is a you know really strong kind of
community around it and you can ask any
questions inside Stack Overflow or in
get appraising issue and then most
people would be able to help however and
kind of there are a couple of things
that tensorflow is trying to improve
these interfaces it's pretty low level
for example Python really shines around
that very clean interfaces and now they
are trying to accommodate that problem
through carries module which is a much
cleaner interface however I think the
terms of love shines really well on the
serving player so they have a binary
they call cancer for serving and this
pioneering makes it really easy to put
the models into production if you have
transfer of state model in in some place
and this notebook is basically shows a
little overview of what cancer was so
close serving is and what does it do
under the hood to kind of get a bit
better understanding what we are going
to do in the next note box in the main
course tensorflow serving it is forming
components these are the green kind of
classes these are all C++ libraries we
have
Python bindings in the tester for
serving exposed to us to be able to use
it or you don't have to use it in the
dockerfile it is completely within the
C++ preamp so you don't actually have to
write any single line of code to be to
be able to use this sensor for serving
but it is good to be able to understand
what's back to the dust under the hood
so the yellow closes our pluggable
implementations which means that you can
actually change these to any type of
thing that you want the file system
doesn't have to be a file system it can
be FTP it can be any type of thing that
can start the model finally stop
servable
it can also be subject to change today
the talk is going to be on transit also
we are going to use tensorflow servable
but you can basically write your C++
library and then as long as you applied
to the transfer for survival kind of
interface you would be able to roll out
your survival model and then use
transfer for serving to be able to serve
that model on the dynamic manager the
version policy actually makes a decision
on how you go out new model so if you
have a older model lytic version one and
then you want to roll out version 2
model then you can do either on/off
switch you can either do Bluegreen
deployment you can also do gradual
deployment where you will route 10% of
the traffic to the new model 200% and
then gradually roll out the model the
version policy makes a decision to that
one and then server will handle actually
handles the request from client and then
get the predictions from the model and
then kind of makes it communication if
you look at the kind of what under the
hood they do is the source is basically
you can kind of consider let's say we
have a model in the file system we are
put that and the first step
the model carving starts in the source
sources Rico the source will recognize
that the model is there it identifies a
model but it doesn't do anything else it
just percent message to load if it did
the model Lord will look at the state
model and then we'll say okay this
requires as much of resource and this is
this type of metadata but the Lord
result also doesn't load the model file
either dynamic manages it passes a
despite version to the dynamic manager
and dynamic manager does the forward
dynamic manager decides how much
resource this model is going to consume
if there is any enough resource on the
machine and if there is it enough
resource to the machine what is the
version pulse of this model if it is a
new brand model it will have a kit
brand-new memory allocation if it is a
update on the currently serving existing
model then it's going to check basically
the deployment strategy on the existing
model to be able to decide how to robot
that model to the production and then
after dynamic manager loads everything
it will be uniquely roll up roll up the
model and then swivel handle we have a
switch to the new model is stopped in
here I mentioned some considerations if
you want to not fail in a request at
runtime you can actually do this but the
resource country on the dynamic manager
that you actually need twice of the
memory so that you can load all ten new
model into memory at the same time and
then will be able to see which one
versus another so that you don't feel
any impolite requests if you don't have
enough resources then the new manager
will do the switch on and off manner but
you are going to fail a lot of requests
in the flight which may not be great
Google had
great kind of talk where they see p99
latencies increase all the time between
12:00 a.m. and 1:00 p.m. and they try to
investigate what the problem is
they were using this one of off switch
on the model and one engineer who is
trying to get his lunch will go to the
lunch but then we'll click on to the
deployment model and then it will
basically deploy the new model which is
great but then since they don't have a
gradual deployment the new end fault
basically is going to fail a number of
requests at that point and then it will
cause a sudden spike on the p99 tt99
latency which is kind of the threat they
figure out a little bit later and then
try to improve the version policy after
that and the ultimate goal on the
transfer clustering is continuous
pipeline continuous training we have a
kind of modeling portion training
pipeline and then you have serving
pipeline you will have you will get a
new data you obtain a new learner and
then the learner will output different
versions of the models and the serving
there that we are going to focus on
today is going to pick up those model
files and then try to produce
predictions so this is kind of ultimate
aim on any machine learning pipeline if
you want to build and as I mentioned
earlier tensorflow
really shines here stands for serving is
great library to be able to do this
really efficiently and innovative
performance in a very performant manner
in the previous talk yes
should so in here this is kind of like a
generic overview so you have a model in
here let's say and if you have the kind
of training portion of it the Python
script that you wrote right it will pull
some data it will learn the weights they
say you are training a CNN it will learn
the weights and then it will output a
model file for you with the weights
under the hood is going to be just a
graph it is in the tons of blog thing
and those weights are going to be
basically your graph that will be your
first model and then tomorrow you are
going to come to office exactly same but
then there is now new data you are going
to learn new ways this time and then you
are going to output another model this
is kind of training pipeline portion
this is happening Class A every day but
then you actually need to do if there is
no serving player what you do is
actually on the serving predictions
portion you actually need to get the old
model kill it
deploy the new model and I start the
prediction process on top of that where
the serving player if you are outputting
in the same file system they say on the
machine it will automatically pick up
the new model file for you let's say you
are outputting into the same directory
and then it will automatically load that
model and not start serving predictions
for you so in here if you actually don't
change anything it automatically picks
up the new model and then serving the
predictions from the start serving
predictions from the new model
you typically start with the weights
that you had already trained the three
distinct and then but initializing
but probably lot of weights and then at
training on top of this victims you know
the data doesn't change a lot that would
be much more efficient and we already
have kind of knowledge on the previous
data side is there any question of so
far and then in the previous talk with
making say talk a little bit about RPC
transfer for serving started RPC
protocol from 1.0 and this was kind of
give a RPC request blob where you have a
number of clients these clients can be
in any way where you have tons of
coromoto servers which we are going to
serve this portion in the docker file
and then you have a number of models
they say we have in the local file
system
what tensorflow serving was doing is
they will accept the G RPC request it
was sorted
Jackie's request by using the models and
I'm passing that data to the model stem
cells and then we'll sort the
predictions up to the up to the client
starting from tons of observing - we no
longer need to use Jack PC although they
still support it just because it is much
more efficient but they still start
supporting to HTTP kind of like a REST
API on top of it so that we don't
actually have to use G RPC and I put in
HTTP on top of the geography see if you
want to really use the HTTP endpoints
for the for the mothers we I will show
what the JRTC component as well as the
REST API
just because tons of for serving model
servers can expose what ports to the to
the local machine but we are going to
only use let's take care today just
because it is easy also
if you are running ten supermodel
servers in the docker then you can just
hit request that get you are out and
then get the predictions or requests
that possible and then get the
predictions from that model on top of
there and how do you kind of peel the
tensor to our model server now we are
going to use docker file just because
these are developed against Ubuntu
machines and for production hopefully
most of us are using Ubuntu machines I
don't I think these would still work in
Windows machines but I don't think they
are and kind of maintaining that portion
for the transsexual model servers do
that kind of very common up get installs
and the interesting pieces are we are
going to have the models to be available
on to the dock limited soft and then the
the TF serving secret which will have
the model configuration we at which we
are going to give and then we are going
to expose a JRTC
and HTTP REST API port and then it will
be basically how we are going to run the
other file and in the docker file after
we load two tons of after we install the
transfer model server we will just run
this run this best-equipped we will give
normal port to it eight five hundred
since transform others have started with
the GRP C there is no Jack PC prefix in
here because they considered this part
to be default port and then the second
part which is the rest api port which
uses the HTTP on top of it we are going
to expose its 501 and then we are going
to pass a model config file which will
give up which will tout where the model
files are to the transsexual model
server and if you look at the
mother's conf this is a very primitive
conflict file which will give the names
of the models and where these models are
and then the model platform we are going
to start the clock as I mentioned
earlier tensorflow serving wants to be a
common serving layer so they support
multiple model platforms as long as
those models will comply the tensorflow
servable
interface in here you can have arbitrary
number of config files for the models
you can have this net which we are going
to use today
Master Zen and which is which we are
also going to use and then you can just
arbitrarily increase this model files on
a single document machine
the only problem the only kind of
limitation is if this model requires X
number of memory
this requires Y number of memory you
need to have X plus y in the post
machine to be able to deploy otherwise
it's going to fail to load this model
files into into memory and docker file
this stuff is basically running that
just not that Sh I kind of want to show
what output it draws when you run this
docker image and it will look at the
model files as I mentioned earlier it
will say okay I have a great nut model
in this directory I have a must are CNN
it may make it a little bit bigger we
are not necessarily interested in the
the cpu support in fact we are going to
have the model files in here it will
also will tell the versions because it
supports multiple versions they say you
have the first version second version
third version it will basically load the
latest model and then it will it will do
the same exact thing for the second
model it will locate the meta graph to
see which employees it needs to expose
yes
yeah we are going to create this since
yeah and we are going to come this one
we are going to load in one of the
notebooks yep you can remove that config
for now yeah yeah and then I you you
can't you cannot can load the second
model and then kind of go from there
the a couple of things in here it kind
of gives warnings for no one up datafile
found it it particular directory another
good thing about transform a low serving
is you can actually create warm-up
requests for your model so that you you
wouldn't have cost a problem if you are
serving
they say search problems you can have
you can load 1000 most commonly searched
terms and then put it into the warm-up
requests so that when your model goes up
it will it will basically gets warmed up
so that you don't have an immediate
latency problems around the most
commonly searched terms and it will be
warmed up before serving the request
this is also purely handled by the
transfer model serving and the latest
two is you have basically GRDC listening
on it 500 and it's five hundred or one
we have an HTTP REST API which is to do
again terms of a model serving at this
point since we have a running docker
file that will have both Jarvis and HTTP
API you should be able to hit localhost
it's five hundred or one true like yet
and then you will get a not successful
dog but it is you would know if there is
something running there and then rest of
the things kind of generic terms of flow
messages the one thing is I wanted to
mention is
it says your CPS supports instruction
that this transfer work when it wasn't
compelled to use in this tutorial
none of the docker files are optimized
Google allows you to do a built for your
hardware so if you have a specific
hardware they say GPU or CPU that they
are offering you can actually built all
docker files and against those Hardware
specific kind of machines and then they
will optimize certain computations for
you under the hood for that particular
hardware which will increase the speed
up quite simply this is true for in GPUs
but even for the CP machines they are
saying P is equal to me that you are
using a transfer for binary that this
machine is not really compatible if you
compile the transexual binary or
transform other server binary with with
machine that you have you may you know
get a a little bit speed up speed out
there and and the docker file that you
can use for that one is in the th
serving docker file this is like a long
docker file it is pretty involved but if
you are gonna kind of improve the
prediction speed up you can just nothing
changes you can just compile this poker
file against the machine that you are
going to run and then it will give you
speed up on top of that and does anyone
knows what GRDC is or remote procedure
call waste we can see also mentioned a
little bit there
remote procedure call I kind of wanted
to mention a little bit the remote
procedure call is basically extracts the
network communication under a protocol
and client doesn't know anything about
it first of all the IPC is basically
Google remote procedure call which they
use under the hood protobufs to make the
communication a little bit faster and
more efficient
and it will give especially since we are
passing large amount of data like images
this actually improves the network
communication as well as the
civilization and the civilization times
on the stronger side so that you will
get a better faster prediction times and
in here if we look at the ERP capi I put
just a reference the gr PC important
actually what they call it a prediction
service this is nothing but a proto file
today they expose a certain interfaces
you may be familiar with the classifier
regress predict and I haven't used multi
importance but if you want to use you
can also use mouse component this is the
basically ERP see a fair contract the
transfer for model server would give you
for a given model weather model supports
or not that is up to the model stuff or
how you save the model but if you if you
can kind of fit these end points to see
if you can get in a you know
classification regression or prediction
and as I mentioned earlier the metadata
is for loader to be able to no
destructive we are also going to look at
them we are also going to look at the
metadata metadata this is attached to
the tensor for model servers on top of
on top of here
and I wanted to give a couple of
pointers and tons of love is a hub this
is kind of you can consider the github
they had a number of reusable machine
learning modules that they kind of
open-source desire a little bit
pluggable one to another you can use
input from somewhere you have a
basically an input portion or the
training of an input portion of a single
model and then I get the second layer or
the third layer of another model and
then kind of compose different models on
top of already trained models so that is
you brought up earlier if you have
already trained model you will basically
get a portion of it you will get the
other portion of it with the weights
initialized and everything and then that
makes it could make training other
efficient as well as you can be of
different architectures very easily and
then you can also look at by module type
different image classifications in here
you can basically get a number of
encoders and everything and the model
were map transfer has a good
documentation around warm-ups as well if
you are interested in learning more
about this and then this go to the
official receiver example so in this one
I wanted to basically give what overview
for the the training as well as the as
well as the production izing pipeline
portion of it in here we are going to
train a basic Ellis model it's not going
to be good but as I mentioned earlier my
main focus is what happens after the you
have the cast model basically we are
going to train a very basic Aires model
we are going to s'appelle this cache
model to the disk and then
after we suppose this to the list we are
going to use this model file into
transit to another server and then load
this locally and then we are going to
eat the rest a camp point to get the
predictions we went through a little is
docker file before we can go one morph
if anybody wants any clarification we
have and under the hood this is the
thing that we are running super model
servers I want this part to be my REST
API this part to be our PC and this is
my model name this is my model base pad
if you have already installed the
required subjects then you should be
able to import these third-party
dependencies I'm using TIF 1.2 12 you
would probably have it it will probably
be good for the kind of most newer
versions but as far as I know it doesn't
work below 1.10 especially on the curves
modules even in this one there are some
warnings that I will show and I'm not
going to run this but you can kind of
run it on your own if you have
third-party dependencies just because I
don't want to do this training portion
of it in here and defining the number of
URLs and since I exposed it 500 or 1 and
I said we are going to use the REST API
endpoints I defined the localhost 8 501
is a base URL so this is going to be
really glad I'm to the point - enough to
model predictions because this is the
rest API endpoint as I mentioned earlier
we are exposing also JRTC
if you want to do GRDC you can just
change this to it's 500 0 0
there is no us spectrum ng RPC but you
can use the same exact post JSON payload
to here but we are not going to use that
and then if you just hit this it
stratosphere out in here and you would
be able to get the stats of the quarter
after I my teen drama from director
the dockerfile that is in the notebooks
directory will give us will give us the
fashion model which is a little bit
misnomer but I will explain why it is
called today okay
and
okay so we hit the models swatch fashion
model this is the model name it will
give us a JSON payload it will give us
version with its state available if
everything is basically okay you can see
various object against the Sun point
kind of like a heartbeat if you want to
learn more about what this model is we
can basically metadata this will give
music model specs but more important
more importantly the signature
definition as well as the input type
kind of what it expects this is going to
be important we need when you are trying
to compose a payload that actually this
model is going to accept so if you are
want to use a model file that is been
open sourced by Google you need to look
at the function signature to be able to
find out what type of data you want to
pass in here we have 20 28 because the
image data set that I used was 28 by 28
you can't change these dimensions
arbitrarily this is up to the up to
completely the model architecture if you
want to have large image files you can
you can do that you can also even
pre-process arbitrary image sizes within
the tensor flow model very easily in
here I'm using 28 528 grayscale images
and a little bit about the data set is
this fashion minused
data set solando a company an e-commerce
company in europe open sources data if
you are familiar with the deep learning
you problem all this means in
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I left
you can't take you seriously with this
patient
so yeah the place we were we were laptop
is the kind of the metadata physically
this model it will give the output and
in here we have the output the softmax
there which will have ten classes and
then we are going to try to predict one
of the one of the classes this is kind
of the input image portion of it and
this is the output portion of it the
good thing is all of them are kind of
our control where you can output
everything in here as I mentioned
earlier to this model is not very good
it is just a single convolutional layer
I'm going to show a little bit better
model but it trains very well and on my
machine it is pure CPU there is no GP or
anything involved so you can just run it
on your local machine and within minutes
it should be complete with reasonable
model accuracy I think it was it's seven
percent yeah it's some percent on the
test accuracy the reason why I use in
here cares is the interface is all the
bit better also it supports a little bit
more like visibility if you want to
understand what the model file is or
anything like this we're in the
low-level terms of implementation it
could be a little bit hidden and after
you have the model in here after you fit
and evaluate the model we are going to
export this using this EF state model
simcoe save this is a little bit
important what we are trying to do is
now we have the model file which you can
actually load into the memory
and everything however for us to be able
to load this tensor for serving model to
tentacle model server we actually need
to use a certain specification and if
the Python developers we actually don't
want to use we actually don't want to
write C++ code for to do so so we are
going to use dental floss state model
and then use this current year session
if we weren't using carrots this will be
just pure a th session the export tab
and then the model input is an input
which will give the input side of the
model to the graph and then the model
outputs as output and if we use this
simple save function we will have an
state model it can easily be loaded into
the tensor form of serving earlier so we
don't actually have to do any work this
is basically what you do if you are
using transfer flow on the training
portion you just need to do a bit of
work in here and then output the model
into a state model structure for us to
be able to load it and if you are
interested in ultimate better model that
actually uses transfer flow I tested
this in the same same data set this
produces 98% almost but it is obviously
much more involved and it may require
kind of GPU computation to be able to
run this successfully and this is a
library the jet open sourced recently so
you can kind of look at this model there
and when you have the model similar to
here I think I provide also main
function you can also basically use the
same simple save to the local directory
and then will be able to get the
prediction and then on the export path
this is a portable file a state model
and then the variables basically the
weights and a number of things that are
going to be useful for that model in
here I want to show a command line tool
state model CLA CLA is available command
line and the state model this tool is
kind of like if you Toto when you pass
the export that which we exported the
model in a state model format you pass
this you give a shop and then you
basically produce everything it will
give very similar to the metadata on the
command line so that you don't have to
have you don't have to eat the metadata
URL on the command line you just export
the model file and then you use this
transfer flow model save model CLI tool
to be able to output the signature
definition input and our output portion
this is very similar to the metadata URL
that we looked at before but if you
don't want to go through that you can
also use a command line tool and the
fashion minced is a 20 by 28 by 28
images to replace means library the data
set I guess it's not really library to
be more applicable in the fashion
category the means is basically a digit
recognition it is great kind of create
very spaced lines but for in commerce
company like the delando
it probably didn't cut it so they
actually come up with a new very basic
data set it is very similar to means
given the dimensions of images but they
have much different classes and it is
still 10 but it is still 10 classes like
the digitizer set that means test is
sample example it would be like this the
reason why it is so bad like this is
because my finger size of the big large
if I do this 4 by 4
it looks a bit better and you can kind
of look it and sample these images in
here what we are going to do is we are
going to create a data since I mentioned
earlier we can do GRDC but in
geographies we actually need to build
protocols to be able to communicate the
geography standpoint on the HTTP side we
don't have to do that we what we need to
do this time since we are going to post
some data we actually need to build a
JSON payload for this one this is
basically after we know the signature of
the of the model we are trying to build
we are trying to build a data payload
that is JSON which has the instances of
what we want to predict test images that
have never been synced to the to the
model a signature name for this case it
doesn't matter but you can also make
distinction between different models on
the response side to the signature name
and then this will be basic large JSON
payload and as I mentioned earlier you
can use requests that get status URL to
be able to do this rather than you know
opening a new web browser or a new tab
and then after this when we have the
data JSON payload that we want to build
on the instances we can just hit this to
the to the pale of this payload to the
prediction and point and it's going to
produce us our predictions maybe I can
actually do
so in here we have we have the data as
an input we have the prediction URL
which is nothing but this one we can use
two different things in here I'll
explain which basically says v1 models
fashion model and then the predict this
predict function is from the protobuf
that we see out of it before it supports
crossfire regress or you can use this or
if you want to be a little bit kind of
more rested you can use this the second
prediction Europe this is useful this is
especially useful when you have multiple
versions and you have a newer version
and you wanna gracefully switch to that
this one basically gives you the kind of
like a proxy URL which will have your
latest model but with this one is
basically curve first version first
first version model is this the second
one is going to be the second say
McCallum predict but when the second one
is loaded into the into the docker you
will have the prediction year of not
changing anything basically reflect the
second model but if you still want to
hit the first one while transitioning
tech you can use the first version
prediction Europe so the under the hood
if you have a single model these URLs
should be exactly same to each other and
then when we have the JSON payload what
we are going to eat is just get the
predictions so the predictions is going
to be this so this is not very useful
the in the sense that is going to be not
going to be a class so what we do is
basically get the art marks of each
numpy array you can consider this as an
amp array these are actually
list and then look at the position of
that nampeya to actually map to the
class that it belongs to
so for these cases these are arbitrarily
very small numbers and the model
actually thinks either this very small
probability with smoke level very small
probability but this is much higher on
the soft mass layer so and then art maps
will give us the position of the maximum
number which ending in here and then we
can look at the class names which will
have the dictionary per position and the
class name and then you can kind of you
can kind of look at the class names look
up through the art mugs and then you can
have the same exact test labels similar
to here and then we can output the what
model is predicting versus what actually
the what actually the image was if one
output kind of multiple images we can
also do that let's do that actually in
here a model thinks it is an ankle boot
actually those ankle boot pull over
flour this dataset is particularly meant
to be very easy data set so it is going
to be most of the time very good even if
the model file is not very good but the
model stuff is not very good so this
concludes basically the first notebook
the second notebook is similar it
involves in the main directory a docker
file this time we are going to run the
list and occur on the main directory
rather than within the notebooks
directory
and in this in this notebook we are
going to use a already trained model
which is pretty famous bestnet to be
able to do image classification on top
of this
and for this particular notebook is so
the personal book is basically giving
you a little bit exposure on training
outputting a model file but tons of flow
has ton of already available models and
if you want to just get one particle
model it would be useful for you and
then start using it you can also do that
and this notebook basically shows you
how you may be able to do so this is
also exactly similar to what we have
before in here instead of plotting the
data we are going to read the image URL
from from a from a URL and then we are
going to encode that into 3 6 2 4 and
then we are going to submit that image
to the to the best net model in here
this is the exactly same but I want to
kind of show today's net URL for the
status and point also you can use the
metadata information like the similar in
a similar way in here I'm going to also
report back how actually passed it is
even if we didn't as I mentioned earlier
we didn't do any optimization at all and
then and now we are going to see some
predictions there so in here I'm
basically going to get 100 requests and
then we'll report back on how long it
actually took to respond from the from
the server side this is not really
likely the truthful I just because there
is no network oh I mean there is little
code but it will be very minimal have a
little show and it will show the
difference between loading a model by
yourself to the session
where
start a flow model serving to get the
predictions from and then in here we are
doing a basic warm-up with the same
image is also not very accurate in real
life the prediction request probably
will be a little bit different than the
warm-up requests that you may have but
nonetheless and we get 140 milliseconds
with the prediction class 286 this is
much kind of larger model as well as the
training site is much larger so this is
a little bit harder and then if you look
at the class this is not exactly right
but it is it you know tries to predict
it is like a cat
it does cougar Zuma mountain lion
so in here you can basically get the
ResNet and numbered in the very similar
way the dockerfile i want to show is
also very similar to the previous
dockerfile
this is the vignette that Sh and the
Ritenour ResNet that Sh is also exactly
same we expose an airport they take care
port and a modest configuration which
which will have it and the third
notebook i want to show up to so far is
there any questions the third pod
notebook
so yeah these are basically it it
requires a little bit warm-up for
loading two weights you can consider it
that way so if you have let's say you
have a Damon Damon has spun tank
processes if not a single process
actually actually did the loading
portion what you are going to have is in
the first they say 100 requests some of
the some of the processes may not have
the same exact configuration so they are
going to do a little bit more work to be
able to tell the predictions but then
when everything kind of loaded
everything works perfectly then you
wouldn't have that kind of distinction
between different if you are serving
like X number of directions per second
you may not be able to see it if you are
serving like thousands that may actually
disturb your p99
and on our case we have citric latency
requirements that we are supporting on
the services so even like very you know
spikes can actually trigger an alert and
on PD needs to responded so we we are
kind of trying to minimize that to this
type of warming up this is also very
common on the databases inspector side
so we try to follow that
approaching here - yes
yes or requesting to you is it the one
that you shall be training in this this
one yeah so that on here the data is I
may not be cleared there it is the test
images so we separated the train images
to the test images the model has never
seen this and then we get the poor first
four instances of those test images in
here I'm converting into lists but this
is because man paydays are not JSON
serializable out of the back but you can
consider this basically an array of
arrays you will have 25 28 for a given
image and then this will give you a four
dimensional array of twenty five twenty
meters and then when you have this is a
multi-dimensional array what I'm doing
is I'm putting this into the instances
which is the witches which is basically
this portion on the training site or you
can consider like this here and then
this is going to be the input portion of
it and then on the output side I am
doing the prediction side which is going
to be there basically they returned
levels in here if you want to look at
the response this is a little bit
actually more
and it runs
so the predictions actually provide kind
of more things but the inputs input side
is here I will also show about it
actually looks like in the instances
that it is basically an array an array
of arrays
is
Oh
two minutes
[Applause]
yeah
the data is going to be a JSON and then
the instances is going to have basically
an array of JSON representation of an
area with NATO service
[Music]
this
because it is
yeah
yeah it is a racecar input it is an
array of arrays and then if you look at
this about
let me show actually this
it's a number a reservation 25:21 and
then the data is itself is basically
string just to get very random substring
piece it
hey we do this
yeah
to 100 it is physically I see realized
every in here into into JSON a number of
zeros and then on the prediction side
this guy
yet predictions is exactly same except
it is under a predictions instance so we
can just use it this is why I had this
variations portion of it and then this
will basically give us all of the sort
marks there travelled is similar to what
we had before
yes that's a call for that I'm supposed
to save Nepal is that the same thing as
you
so this is APB file photo op
however frozen graph is a little bit
different and frozen graph output is
basically giving a check points
mechanism in here we don't have check
points at all we basically say we are no
longer interested in continuing trained
in training anymore
for tests on the frozen graph if you
look at the check points it has a
metadata check points index yada yada
frozen graph means that the training up
to that portion is done if you are using
batch or anything like this they say you
have 200 patches 120 you wanna output
that 120 but the main idea that it's
filling that is actually to be able to
continue from there so that you don't
actually have to do that work over and
over you will blow up basically that's
frozen graph and then both the
checkpoint checkpoint Waits and then
continue their training portion in here
we don't have that mechanism we are
currently utilizing a model into a
format which is the safe model so that
we can load this tape model into the
transfer for serving format which is a
temporal servable interface so they are
elevated different but they both so this
sort of a file saved all the weight and
everything yes within the profile this
one is the other one
but actually it is a little bit
different it was to save the same exact
things on the weights it will just use
the check points file on the metadata to
to see very laptop otherwise the product
will have the weights except you have to
check points will tell you basically
this was my progress this was where off
my laptop so that it will store the
session in this mechanism we cannot be
restored the session because it is
basically done done the you know model
filing mobile storing is basically in
here a kind of basically the same except
it's just the addition of the check mark
on its correct out I want to say yes but
it would probably be very similar
however on the frozen graph I don't
actually know if they comply with the
terms of closer and write my hesitancy
is just because I didn't see any usage
loading the frozen graph itself but
rather what they are suggesting is
generally produce a specific state model
so frozen graph would be probably very
similar however I don't know if we can
interchangeably use them everything
so the second example is this and the
turtle example we have the object
detection example I don't want to kind
of go through this completely this is
also very similar to what we have this
is the earlier config file that you can
that you can get this this here it is in
the same you can't kind of look at the
you can kind of look at the influence
portion of it and then on the HTTP REST
API
I'll be here you can may be implementing
on the on the HTTP side by storing the
by storing the test api portion it will
be very similar to what we had before in
here it is a little bit more involved
I'll try to explain a little bit more
the image generation as well as the
other things are exactly same we are
also using a trained model from Google a
system of walnut which is pretty
efficient and in here if you look at the
frozen inference crap this is also TB
but we have a number of things the same
model is kind of different directory and
everything so if we were able to change
interchangeably they would probably not
you know output everything because if
you download this from Google this this
link if you want to kind of do transfer
learning or if you want to improve the
model file you will probably use frozen
inference graph with the checkpoint stem
cells however if you want to just use
the model that they trained out of the
box you will just use a safe model
directly and then the protocol and the
variables are going to be there they're
there for you
in here I again shot state model CLI one
more time and the kind of model name
exactly exactly same in here we are
loading to grab I wanted to kind of show
whatever you are putting kind of you can
vote into the into the memory very
easily if you want to still use it for
certain string operations as well as
kind of veto functions you can still
output a file and voted data into memory
kind of separate than from the model
portion of it in here this is basically
getting from the frozen graph the pepto
labels is also in them into memory
the image is itself is being converted
to a kind of non pay rate that it will
require and then the if you want to have
the graph and then in the inference
portion of it this is kind of a little
bit different than the serving side now
we have the change a graph and then we
want to basically get the predictions in
memory you will stop bill to input input
size of things in here if you follow the
image you will basically get a image
transfer the run inference is going to
be on on the session itself which is as
I mentioned earlier is not going to be
very efficient and then on the out
protect us you still need to do a number
of manipulations so arguably by creating
a transfer for serving model you are not
actually losing as much I would argue
and then the inference itself is going
to be exactly the same
you
and kind of all of the creative the
detection detection boundaries on the
images themselves and for the rest api
out of that state model it is exactly
the same we can kind of try on your own
I'll be here you have the state model I
already provided to docker file on the
main directory you can get the state
model there it is just pure data
manipulation from the image itself and
to the to the to the data JSON payload
to be able to get detection boundaries
and then I want to show the only fashion
in these models before it I didn't go
through if you want to use kind of
production data models and as I
mentioned earlier transit vlog is not
very good in terms of the interfaces
that they provide but you can create
your own class to build different kind
of networks I kind of like building a
class and then attracting a number of
functions and then create the network
within the within the class in here you
can very easily follow the network
architecture in here you have basically
two CN n layers the max blue layer and
then another to CNN layers and then we
have another multiple layer these are
basically two exact same you can't even
abstract away this kind of networks
similar to kind of pie chart approach
and then on top of it
you can have your input and output
prediction structure on the transfer for
serving to defining here rather than
hard coding on the on the state model to
be able to run
session on top of it so that you will
have a proper - on the class itself and
then you have basically the input sites
and improbabilities this is basically
what we did for the fashion means model
as well this abstract as well as makes
it really easy to be able to use the
tensor flow itself on the pants of
twelve serving side and then if you have
basically kind of different linear
functions on top of the class you can
abstract away quite a bit there on the
training side and then on the on the
saving side you can still use same exact
thing if you are implementing the same
interface onto the top lot save and then
save the model on the TF estimator side
and then kind of get the predictions
this is basically all I have for today
if you have any questions or have
trouble in running notebooks I would be
able to help but is it
[Applause]